blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman okay let's start with something
that a lot of people have asked me to
talk about on the show this is really
interesting the latest
right-wing buzzword that's getting
people fired up and angry is
critical race theory republicans are
absolutely and completely against the
teaching of critical race theory in
schools
they want to ban it they believe it's
terrible it might even be communist or
socialist it's really really bad
but they don't actually know what it is
check out this interview that mark
lamont hill did with former georgia
congressman vernon jones a trumpian
favorite who is really against critical
race theory but he has
no idea what it is check this out what
is critical race theory
well actually i think it's different
depends on who's teaching
and how they're teaching i think you can
agree with that we were taught that
christopher columbus discovered america
well you and i both know that
christopher columbus got lost
people are already living here but there
are those who are using their own
ideology
and their own party affiliation to go to
the extreme
and that's all i'm trying to address
here but what is that what does that
have to do with critical race theory
let me just pause i'm trying to
understand though
you oppose critical race theory which i
understand i'm just asking
what is it what is the thing you define
it like for example if i said i'm
against creationism
i would say creationism is x y and z
right if i said i was against
the teaching of sex education i said
well sex education is x y and z and i'd
have a basis for it
what is critical race theory well
first of all again i can tell you but
it's left up to you to understand i
can't make you understand the fact of it
is
the critical race theory even on this
basis
should not be taught in our schools
period now if you can't understand what
is it
if you want to debate well to me what it
does
to me my interpretation as well as many
others no not what it does what is it
how do you define it i mean it asks you
to define critical race theory
because my audience may not know
well you don't know and you have i said
obviously you don't know and you haven't
told your audience
but again how i see it and how i don't
know receive
well well then what is it then no what
is it then okay well i'm happy to answer
that for you
but your answer you're saying just
answer i'll tell you what i will
you're you're saying that on day one
on day one here's the question first
answer the first question
i promise i'll answer your questions so
you get the picture vernon jones just
doesn't know what it is that's just one
example but this is the bottom line
they continue to attack critical race
theory without actually
indicating that they know what it is
when they're asked what it is they seem
to have no
idea or they say critical race theory is
the idea that every white person is a
white supremacist oppressor
now we should understand what critical
race theory is and i want to be really
clear that
critical race theory is not my primary
lens through which i view the world i
find it reductionist but i'm going to
tell you what critical race theory
is and then you can research more you
can decide whether you think it's an
accurate lens or whether it should be
part of your
uh world view okay the way i see
critical race theory
is a sort of race reductionism now if
you've heard the term
class reductionism there's a very simple
analogy
to at least give us an initial basic
understanding of critical race theory
although it's not
nuanced enough and i admit that class
reductionists believe
that at some fundamental level any
division any problem
any conflict any inequality in society
in politics in an economy even if it
seems it might be caused by many things
is actually about class something that
to a class reductionist something that
looks like a racial issue
to a class reductionist it's really a
problem
caused by class differences and the
racial factors
may just be confounding or they may be
coincidental or they may not even be
relevant so
to make a very rough analogy to
give us a start in understanding
critical race theory critical race
theory
would analogously argue that what might
seem like a class problem
or an economic problem or a political
problem
that it is actually fundamentally a
problem of
race and racism in the us specifically
it would be racism
generally by white people against
non-white people
in particular against black americans
now that's the most
basic explanation it's far more detailed
as an area of academic research now for
30 years and really even more than that
uh the roots of critical race theory are
in the 60s and 70s
but um without getting into you know a
more nuanced definition would include
the idea of creating subgroups of humans
developing
law and systems that are inherently
racist and designed
to maintain these inequalities between
whites and non-whites
and you can use that analysis when you
look at any system you can look at the
education system
through the lens of critical race theory
or the election system and on and on
now there are undoubtedly many ways in
which
aspects of critical race theory are
completely accurate
where i disagree with critical race
theory much the same way i disagree with
class reductionism
is that i don't think anything is quite
so simple on a planet of 7 billion
people
in a country of 331 million like the us
we can never really say this
issue is solely informed by
one thing whether it's race whether i've
never found an issue
where race is the one lens through which
we understand it or class is the one
lens or
geography is the one it's just never
been that way
on any issue i've studied but this is
not about my view
this is about the reality that the very
people angrily denouncing critical race
theory
have no idea what it even is now i want
to say one other thing about that
this is not uncommon think about the
usage
of the term socialist during the last
presidential election i've asked lots of
these people
when i interview them or when they call
in or when you know whatever what do you
mean
socialist and they have no idea what it
means but they use it and they believe
joe biden is one
now cartoonishly as one example here's
what happened when conservative
jessie lee peterson brought it up when i
visited his studio in los angeles
um and the topic of socialism came up
during the trump administration take a
look
because it's the straight white
conservative christian man
who's holding the country together oh if
it wasn't for them america would be
associated with society already it would
be what a socialist
society how would it become if you see
if you notice the average black man has
no authority no power the mexican
doesn't have any
is that white straight conservative
christian man
that is preventing them from turning
this country
into a you know socialist society but so
here let me ask you about this
i'm not a socialist myself i'm a social
just to be clear i'm
i don't i'm not advocating for socialism
i don't know that many
actual socialists like who would who
where's the big desire for the u.s to
become socialist
if you look at the democratic party
there's almost no socialists in the
democratic party
communist party now what's one that's
one socialist idea from the democratic
party um
uh socialized healthcare no that's a
social social democracy
program no denmark socialist and if you
notice that barack obama
the fallen messiah you know he's the the
messiah right
i don't know anything about that well i
beat mama michelle uh he tried to turn
america into a socialist society what's
one example of a socialist policy that
he had
uh socialized health care he didn't do
that he did for-profit obamacare taking
care of everybody how so uh by getting
rid of jobs
many people mostly took care of people
about getting rid of full-time jobs and
they had to work two
part-time jobs in order to survive so
you don't even understand the talking
points
the rest stopped working and just went
and depended on and relied on the
government
free obama phones
that's socialist socialism so how can
you do so
i want to ask a real question i'm asking
you a real question
obama phones are not socialism no i'll
answer your question let me ask you a
real
i really want to know this the arguments
against places like venezuela and cuba
and other so-called socialist countries
are that
no one has anything no one can afford
anything
there's no technology there's no food
but you're saying that
cell phones for people are socialism
yeah is that that's your argument yes
right that's an example of it yeah
so the point is there's no difference
here they don't know what socialism is
they don't know what critical race
theory is the first
step in every single one of these
conversations should be
ask them to define the terms and you
will very quickly
see that they have no idea what they are
talking about
the arrests continue for people involved
in the january 6th trump riots and the
justice department has now
charged a soldier in the wisconsin
national guard for his involvement
in the insurrection on january 6th
abram markowski and an associate report
cnn allegedly traveled to washington dc
together to attend
trump's protest against the
certification of the 2020 election
after the rally investigators say
markowski and his associate walk to the
capitol
spent 40 minutes inside the building
markowski has been charged
with four federal crimes including
violent entry
or disorderly conduct as of this morning
he has not yet
entered a plea markowski is one of the
nearly
three dozen current or former service
members charged in connection with the
january 6th
attack says cnn based on a review of
pentagon records and court documents
the majority are veterans including many
who served in iraq and afghanistan
but markowski is part of a smaller group
in that he is or at least was
a current member of the military
this is not hugely shocking in the
immediate aftermath
of the january 6th trump riots we knew
that there was not only
a military presence but a law
enforcement presence i'm not saying
to defend the capital there was that but
i'm saying in terms of the perpetrators
and now we are
learning more about the specifics of
this over-representation
in the group of rioters
in the defendants charged with their
involvement on january 6
military and law enforcement are
over-represented although not by as much
as it maybe looked like
earlier on now this uh action
by markowski seems to be in violation
not just a federal law
but also of the national guard oath it
looks like it's in violation
of an article banning mutiny and
sedition the national guard
oath says i solemnly swear that i will
support and defend the constitution of
the u.s
and of the state of whatever because
national guards are state national
guards against all enemies foreign and
domestic
i will bear true faith and allegiance to
them and i will obey the orders of the
president of the united states
and the governor of whatever state and
the orders of the officers appointed to
me
according to law and regulations clearly
a violation by participating in the riot
of the national guard oath but then also
looking at article 94
on mutiny and sedition any person
subject to this chapter
who with intent to usurp or override
lawful military authority refuses
in concert with any other person to obey
orders or otherwise do his duty
or creates any violence or disturbance
is guilty
of mutiny that is
exactly what the january 6th riots were
about
so although the charges so far are just
federal
i'm seeing significant reason that there
should be
charges here under the u.s code of
military justice as well
at least for this individual if not for
others as well
now in terms of you know consequences
and penalties
it's just too early there are certainly
people who are going to do some jail
time
for their participation in the january 6
riots many are going to plead out
and we just have to wait and see but
continuing to see active service members
uh charged in their involved for their
involvement in the january sixth riots
let me know what you expect as far as
sentencing on some of these will
being a member of the military be an
aggravating factor in sentencing
or will it be a mitigating factor in
sentencing if indeed we get to that
point
let me know you can find me on twitter
at d pacman
we have a perfect perfect show
for you today glad you're with us what
if you could read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
made possible
by members who sign up at
joinpackman.com
everyone is very very special
let's go to the phone lines at
davidpakman.com
slash discord starting with
uh oh i don't know let's start with
let's start with dj
from montana dj from montana you're on
the air
uh hi david how are you can you hear me
yes i can i'm doing great uh my name is
david tu
um i am gonna pay my subscription in two
days and i couldn't be more proud
and i just wondered if you could tell
everyone something that
that drives you to do what you do uh
maybe there's an event or a person in
the past
that's all thanks no there is no such
event or person i hate
i mean it's you know we i want to inform
the people
i want people engaged i want people uh
committing to things that are important
to that to them it's not up for
to me to tell you what what that should
be but hopefully to let you know that
there are things happening in the world
that you should be paying attention to
and that your involvement is
um uh a good thing and that we should
all aspire to get involved but there i
sadly have no
um black swan event i can point to uh
david
well that's okay thanks for your time
all right very good and we will welcome
that membership payment with wide open
arms as you can imagine
let's instead try billy from california
billy from california you're on the air
hey david hey you hear me
yes oh sorry hey hey
i just wanted to talk quickly about uh
actually masking so
you know based on tbc guidelines if
you're vaccinated now you don't have to
wear a mask
outside i started working in my downtown
office
again since i've been fully vaccinated
and i'm walking to the office every day
and i'm
not wearing my mask but i see everyone
else wearing a mask and i almost feel
like obligated to do so just kind of
like
i don't know like a sense of camaraderie
or like hey i'm i'm
like you know trying to be safe and look
out for other people too but
now hold on when are you so weird when
you say you walk into your office not
wearing a mask
you're not saying in inside the masks
are still required right you're saying
outside oh
sure sure sure no i meant like i park
you know away from the office
and i when as i'm walking through
downtown to my office
there's uh you know people wearing masks
and that and you know you walk by them
and they kind of look at you funny if
you're not wearing a mask and it's like
hey like
i'm back you know you don't want to just
start shouting people on your
vaccinations i'm vaccinated yeah
no i know i'm seeing the same thing in a
lot of different places i mean listen
here's the deal
um if there's a line at the grocery
store and i'm standing outside in the
line
and everybody's wearing a mask i'm going
to put the mask on because that's kind
of like a specific situation and so i
want to be kind of part of the team
when i go out running now there's still
a lot of people wearing masks
and i'm not wearing a mask you know i am
fully vaccinated
i don't think we ever really needed
masks in that situation i
but i followed the cdc guidelines all
along i continue to follow them i think
and and i have a high level of comfort
nobody has given me a dirty look but if
they did i wouldn't care i'd be totally
comfortable i'm doing what the cdc says
sure so i think it's a very personal
thing some people are more
impacted by the social pressure some are
not i think the important thing is are
we following the guidelines
fair enough yeah and i well i agree and
i guess downtown's a little different
because you do have
it's not crowded yeah but at the same
time it's not sparse so when you're
walking down the sidewalks you are like
a few feet from people
but again the data shows that that's low
transmission rate
yeah you know the thing i'm also
wondering is that when i see
that even though the guidelines have
changed i'm wondering number one
are these people aware of the change but
they're just not vaccinated sure
so that's why they're doing it or have
people not even heard about the change
yet that's also possible
that's the other thing too like maybe
we're more in obviously we're more in
tune to it
right read the news and stuff like that
but i don't think
everybody does that i don't think
there's been a big i haven't seen any
cam
you know ads or psas um really saying
things
i agree no there's been no commercials
saying you no longer have to wear your
mask outside i think over the next
couple months though it'll roll out and
you'll see
fewer and fewer outdoor masks yeah
um another thing too if you just for a
minute um as
as we're kind of reopening and getting
back together like we finally were able
to visit with
my family you know my brother my sisters
and
my mom and my dad since everyone's fully
vaccinated you know we brought our kids
over there and it was
you know really great to be around them
but you know as we're going forward and
kind of reopening and getting back
together with people
yeah i do still have some family members
that are are
maga or or anti-vaxxers and i know
they're not gonna get the vaccine and
it's
it just kind of hurts because it's like
well i want to see these people and i
want to be around these people
right and i don't really have any ill
will as like a
you know family to family but i mean
that's
gonna be tough there's i've heard a lot
of stories like that where i know so
many people
i don't personally know anyone not
getting vaccinated but lots of the
people i know
do know people not getting vaccinated
and many of them are saying
we've just told them we will only be
around you
outside if you're not vaccinated period
some are being even more extreme and
saying listen i'm just not going to see
you at all
but a lot a lot i know are saying listen
we're just gonna have to see each other
outside if you refuse to get vaccinated
yeah yeah and it's tough you know with
with young kids i
i my wife and i are pretty protective so
i don't even know if we would
become too comfortable with that sure to
each their own but
absolutely yeah that's gonna be
interesting going forward
all right my friend thank you for the
call
take care uh i hope you're doing well
because you didn't mention
that you were doing well before you
started calls so you know
i'm doing well thank you for asking yeah
very good okay
all right thanks everybody i will see
you soon uh okay
um a lot of concern for whether i am
doing well today
let's go next to samuel from
brooklyn samuel from brooklyn you're on
the air
hello hello hi
david uh nice to be on the show likewise
like nice to be on yours the show of
your life i guess
yeah um it's it's so strange i felt i
i don't know i just felt like you were
gonna choose me but anyway
uh that's besides the point i wanted to
talk a little bit about uh sort of media
literacy
and media criticism and that kind of
thing
and because uh it's part of like my
college curriculum
that kind of thing okay studying uh
these topics and uh i recently watched
uh this film i don't know if you've
heard of it
but it's called network and
it's it's supposed to be this this this
satirical like
farcical uh portrayal of
news media and
note that this was this was done like 40
years ago
but watching this film it felt
like i've seen this before it it just
reminded me of like fox news tropes of
using like false
outrage to to generate viewership
uh is my connection okay your
connection's fine i'm wondering if you
had a question
nah i just wanted i just wanted uh to
like hear your thoughts
about uh how
we would actually go about solving like
the
the major uh issue that is
media literacy and that kind of thing
yeah
yeah so that's a big topic now i don't
when you say the issue
i don't know if you're talking so you
gave an example of what news media
is broadcasting but your issue your
concern is more media literacy what's
your specific what ex which problem
specifically are you talking about
well just uh the general population and
their understanding of
um what what a real
like something that you can really like
focus on or be
be angry about or or want to change
rather than these sort of full
populist um rhetoric type
stuff that doesn't really have any
substance to it
it's not like a real uh issue that
anyone's
truly concerned about or is actually
happening
yeah that's not so much a media literacy
issue that's more about
the salacious nature of uh the salacious
leanings of
news uh the news industry towards
these cultural issues and away from
um from policy because of ratings and
because of the financial motive but
there's a lot wrapped up there and i i
really do apologize because it sounds
like you you do have something in mind
but i'm not understanding exactly the
question but let's keep
working through these issues and we i
think will ultimately come to
hopefully a better understanding okay i
appreciate the call very very much
let me go next to nico from is it
spartanburg what state is that
uh that would be a city at all in south
carolina
no i know that spartanburg is not one of
the 50 states but yes i was asking what
very good south carolina beautiful
please please proceed governor
uh well uh i really like your show and
how much time you kind of invested into
it
really pump out a lot of videos but i
guess i was curious what kinds of things
you do in your free time
i'm just someone who chills out with
video games and youtube
but i was just curious about you okay
yeah i
uh i play drums i run i bike
i garden i uh have
social calls with friends and family
i travel um i
garden yes i do than usual grace time
it's uh yeah it's a throwback it's a
throwback for sure
is it cathartic to plant some things or
dig up or what exactly kind of gardening
uh the digging up is more cathartic but
you try to avoid that because then you
just kill everything you know you wait
until the end of the season to do the
digging up
right yeah okay i'm just curious
yeah i mean you know i wish i had
something more exciting you know i mean
i guess
traveling as much as possible but that's
been limited during the pandemic i did
go to aruba a couple
couple months ago i've i've traveled
before in my life
um with some missionary parents
but currently just as a general thing
you know if it tells me oh that's all i
do is just
play video games and you know watch way
too much youtube and read it but
right yeah everyone have everyone has
their own thing and um you know
gardening is pretty chill too
yeah yeah i would say so all right well
i hope my hobbies didn't uh
upset you or disappoint what no no
i was just curious i couldn't think of a
question and i joined because i was like
i'll just ask that
if i get chosen so beautiful all right
my friend great to hear from you
thank you okay there is nico from
spartanburg
not a state but a uh city in south
carolina
let's go next to steph from wisconsin
steph you're on the air well hi david
so um i actually had a question kind of
following up the person who
went before the spartanburg person okay
um
and it's about media literacy so do you
think it's possible to get to a level of
media literacy
that the majority of american people
would be able to watch something like
fox news and understand that
much of what they've reported on is
actually just opinions
i think yes because a majority just
means 51
and i think that's achievable i think
that's achievable i think that if you
said
80 percent you know if we got to sort of
propaganda herd immunity for lack of a
better term
where enough people would understand
that you don't want to
signal boost fox news because then it
just spreads like a virus
i think 80 would be tough but yeah i
think we could definitely i mean listen
i think
35 to 40 percent of the country already
gets it
so i don't think that it's unreasonable
to think we could get to it to majority
level yeah
okay and do you think um it's mainly
passed down like
i guess not passed down but is it is
media literacy primarily
um taught in schools or within families
social circles
i wish it were more taught in school but
unfortunately i think that
there are parents who vary either
uh explicitly but sometimes implicitly
with other uh things teach kids to think
for themselves but also to understand
whether
their beliefs are based on something
solid or something flimsy
and so i i think it would be great
if media literacy was actually being
learned and taught
in school more frequently unfortunately
i don't think it is and it really
depends on
on what's going on at home and
unfortunately what's going on at home is
not so good for a lot of people
and that's why i've been advocating that
media literacy and
and critical thinking and epistemology
would ideally start being taught at age
11
to everybody 10 11 12 somewhere in there
you think that late uh i mean i think
you can do things
early you i think earlier than that you
can do
you can do things i think in third
fourth grade
but it would have a little bit of a
different flavor and tone i think they
they would be precursors
precursors but like real media literacy
probably
you know early middle school yeah from
what i've read
okay that's interesting yeah um one last
question
would producer pat start and only fans
okay well we will talk with what are you
looking to see on the only fans i guess
is the question i could i could
talk to him about it yeah ask him about
maybe
him doing hot yoga okay uh all right
steph very
good we will look into that and report
back okay perfect
all right there's steph from wisconsin
very very interested in
uh the producer pat only fans content
all right that's too
crazy a call so let's take a quick break
we will regroup
let things calm down if you're holding
don't hang up because i'm going right
back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
okay let's hear from a few more people
via the david pakman show discord
please uh sign up i mean it's completely
free i'm selling you nothing
at davidpakman.com discord let's talk to
uh oh i don't know how about how about
megan from california megan or megan the
californian is that
better said megan hi how do you hear me
i can hear you fine hi um this is crazy
i
this is my first time calling in i
listen to you every day so thank you
hi um so i yeah i'm from california as
you said
um but i live in england oh wow
and yeah yeah quite the distance um
i don't know if you heard about it but
did you hear about the anti-protest bill
that was
passed here um or at least i did
i did but i introduced rather i don't
remember yeah not past introduced
i don't remember this exactly what's in
it but i remember it raising a number of
red flags
yes um definitely a red flag razor um
i just was wondering like with the
introduction of the anti-protest bill
in florida yeah and that you know
eventual signing and
now this one in the uk which is
obviously
you know basically a cousin of the us
so to speak like is there a growing
like i guess anti-protest movement that
is
actually moving in a way that we should
be genuinely concerned about because
i feel like it is um i think so i think
so
what we could do on that well i think
the problem with a lot of these bills
is that and and to some degree there's
there may be no avoiding this
a lot of these bills are designed the
florida one i'm most familiar with
they're designed in a way where it's
basically just
the discretion of whoever the hell
either wants to support or repress
a particular protest movement because
they i think with the florida one there
was something about
once there is once there's more than
three p it's like some really low number
it's like once there's more than three
people
if they are doing harm to property or
putting property at risk of harm then it
can be completely shut down and people
get arrested
and of course the risk of harm to
property
is so subjective uh that
it's just opening the door to saying
well
we don't like the reason that this
protest is happening so then we're going
to apply the law to it
but then we won't apply it to this other
thing so i think it's extraordinarily
dangerous
is obviously like i mean not obviously
but
it seems like the only answer to this is
more protest
um right but before we have to protest
before they pass the laws yeah
no it's i mean listen i think i think
there's something else though i i do
think that this is one of those
issues where you a lot of these
decisions are being made
at the state level to really all be made
at the state level or even lower
sometimes it's individual municipalities
it's way easier for people to come
together and lobby their local or state
officials than it is
like u.s senators and u.s congressmen so
i think that this is a much bigger
opportunity
for people to really get involved and
work directly with your lawmakers
to change or prevent these types of
bills in a way that is not
as as feasible at the national level
right so it's more of a matter of
contacting your local lawmaker
yes combined with pro going out probably
yeah right okay
so don't don't stop protesting keep
protesting
yes and call your local lawmakers
exactly exactly and vote people
out vote people out if they support this
stuff yes
obviously of course yeah well perfect
phone call thank you david
where in the uk are you did you say
london
no i'm in manchester manchester oh okay
i've never been there i've been to
i've been to london i've been to oxford
i've been to a few other places but
never
manchester is a sizable city right
yes um i would say it's like diet london
um you know if you want to have
a little bit of a smaller um city
and you know uh the locals are great
come come on to manchester the
architecture is beautiful
and aren't things are things opening now
with the numbers looking so good in the
uk
well yes and no it's a it's a mix sort
of thing like the
essential businesses and non-essential
businesses i think are
open now so but
uh you can't go inside of restaurants
i believe i haven't really been out too
much um you can go
and sit in like a beer garden which
obviously brits are
thrilled about beautiful and um yeah
it's
it's good but at the same time i'm
honestly kind of concerned about
the well i'm always concerned about this
government here
right with johnson in charge so i
i am nervous about the release of
the you know astrazeneca vaccine
and stuff throughout the country just
because i don't i don't really trust
them
but maybe that's just more personal
are you wearing a mask outdoors oh of
course i wear a mask
all the time indoors outdoors everywhere
even by yourself at home everywhere just
all the time
uh you know personally when i'm alone
sometimes i like to be a little risky
take it off yeah
you know all right well listen stay uh
stay safe okay thank you all right very
good
appreciate the call thank you um a lot
happening there that's for sure
let's talk to where else do we want to
go
what about um what about
mark dyson from los angeles
hello hello hello
what's going on all right
they hung up i guess they were not quite
prepared let's go to emmanuel
from new york emmanuel you're on the air
hey you can hear me
yes i can i uh i want to ask you about
um
what's going on in myanmar um you know
about all right i'm sorry what's going
on where in myanmar
i'm myanmar yeah i have not been
following it no
okay basically this is recently uh
students and union people you know those
type of people yeah they said they've
been they've been training
in the um in the jungles because what
they're doing
um and um
they know because like the government is
killing protesters like 700 people
already dead already
like i wonder like because this is
because like like in syria the same
thing basically happened in syria which
led to a civil war do you think it
might actually happen in myanmar i wish
i knew more about it from what i'm
seeing in the new york times uh
the um the the the
military seized power killed more than
750
civilians and um the
uh it seems as though an understanding
of the persecution
suffered by the rohingya went more
mainstream more people became aware of
what's going on
and uh resistance escalated around
early february and there is violence
there is resistance to military rule
people are talking about a soft coup
i don't i i'm just i'm just the wrong
person to ask i just don't know enough
about it to be able to predict
i have one more question sure
this is actually gonna hit you close
because
if i'm argentina so i was wondering like
you heard about the pink tide
that's um yes
yeah basically like um the pink type
like um
it's like latin america because i'm also
from it
um because like countries and i had to
make became more conservative
yeah just recently argentina recently
passed they
are not audrey just became abortion
argentina
legalized um abortion yes
and they have a new president who's like
centuries left
and um yeah i don't know about that i
mean i call them kind of corrupt left i
don't know about centrist left
but there is a relatively new president
in argentina yeah
yeah yeah and i i don't know much about
argentinian argentina
but i do know it's conservative as hell
so um yeah you know i don't i don't know
that i agree with you on that it's not
even even the conservatives the
conservatism in argentina
is in my view far more
left than the conservatism in the united
states but like not even close not even
close
and the left in argentina is also more
left than in the united states i'm not
sure i i see that uh
the way you see it i know i could like
i'm [ __ ] i'm i'm mexican salvadorian and
like you know those two countries um
they're like
right in those countries are pretty you
know conservative here's the thing
that's tough about latin america
sometimes looking at it through an
american lens which is
a lot of these latin american countries
are
very catholic but they're catholic more
in the way
that italians are catholic where it's
like yes you're catholic but you're not
an evangelical christian where you vote
exclusively based on
those elements of your worldview it's it
means something different
uh catholicism in latin america so i
don't i don't it's it's just a different
paradigm
yeah but like um i've been knowing
anything recently that
a lot of lefting wing or central left
been like getting elected most recently
and the stuff the protests have been
going on in
south america like do you think that the
left might
make a comeback in latin america sorry
that that the right will make a comeback
the left oh the left i think so i think
yes i think so i think there are but i
think there are many signs of that for
sure
yeah all right thank you so much for the
call i appreciate your questions
welcome all right there we go um
why don't we speak next to
uh let's speak to rashad from is it
staten island
yup exactly what's going on
all right so david i um i've been kind
of thinking about this recently i mean
it's not very
i guess it's more of a shower thought
that i had okay but
i actually think that biden
would have well bernie would have done
worse to trump in the general election
and you know that may or may not be a
hot tape you know but i don't think
bernie would have won georgia
i don't think bernie would have won
arizona
and i just think biden has more appeal
with the
because as much as people don't as much
as leftists online
don't like to realize it you know most
democrats that actually
vote not just tweet on twitter
most democrats actually both prefer the
more moderate candidate and
it's more interspersed throughout the
country yeah i mean this is not
you know whether it's a hot take or not
this this you almost verbatim that was
my analysis
during the democratic primary and for me
it's less about
you know some people some people
speculate and i think it's idle
speculation
that bernie would have done better than
biden in the general election my
question has always been
what evidence do you have of that i've
not seen any
the primary wasn't close and
especially when you think about some of
the states you're talking about
i i don't see how bernie would have done
better than biden
um if someone can explain it to me i'm
willing to have my mind change but i've
certainly seen no evidence of that
yeah it's just it just kind of bugs me
sometimes online
yeah when i see you know like leftists
will blame
like everything from bernie lewis can't
see the
the um the shadow app
they blame everything else except the
fact that the fact that people
voted for biden over bernie i mean
yeah bernie won in california but you
know california wasn't exactly about to
go red
anytime soon yeah no this is like my
analysis of this is not
based on what i would like the truth to
be
it's just the democratic electorate is
not well represented by what you see on
reddit and twitter and we learned that
in the primary and i don't think there's
anything controversial about saying that
i think if we don't recognize it it
certainly won't change the first step is
accepting what the reality is
yeah i i totally agree with you well
thank you david my pleasure to call
great to hear from i appreciate the call
uh thanks to everybody who called in
i'm out of time i am unable to take more
calls today
but there will be future days on which
phone calls are taken
and i look forward to speaking to you
then
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him
okay let's get into audience questions
the first one one that i am asked so
often david why does it appear to be
more profitable to be a right-wing
grifter
than it does to be a left-wing grifter
either someone who
pretends to have changed sides or have a
political awakening
or simply put out ideas that even they
don't believe
merely because it makes money there are
two reasons why
right-wing grifting is so much more
popular than left-wing grifting
the uh the the two reasons are number
one
the left doesn't really care about
people who have these opposite
supposed awakenings or come to
realize that what they've been fed by
their side as wrong or whatever the left
doesn't care about it in the same way
and number two
there's just less money available on the
left for it so we'll explain these one
by one
the idea of someone who
used to be on the left and now is on the
right
as someone we should pay particular
attention to is much more exciting
to the right the left doesn't care
people call into the show all the time
and say i had an awakening i'm on the
left now i used to be a right winger i
fell down the rabbit hole
it's interesting in the sense that i'm
curious how did you get out because we
know it's tough to get out
but my reaction is a very muted oh so
you looked at the facts and now you
better understand things you're no
longer falling for propaganda
you now understand the real world and so
of course now you're on the same side
i'm on which is the site of empiricism
and facts and so on and so forth
now let's try to get something done
let's get the right people elected let's
try to fix some some problems in society
what you see on the right is completely
different when dave rubin
supposedly had an awakening from being a
bernie guy
to saying liberalism is a mental
disorder he was ushered into prageru
to do a video about how he left the left
when candace owens i mean candace owen's
story is a little more nuanced because
for identity reasons she's also really
interesting to the right but
she has this story it may be real it may
be not how she grew up in a democratic
house and i think it was connecticut or
whatever and then she figured out all
these things
the right sees that and they celebrate
it in some kind of defiant heroic
reaction whereas the left when when it
happens just says oh you were you were
uninformed great now
now you're now you're with us but let's
go to the next thing
it's not it's just not as interesting to
the audiences and
case in point many people may not
remember
jenk yuger has taught host to the young
turks has talked about how
when he was young he was a reactionary
conservative republican he was i think
in the republican
club in college whatever every once in a
while it comes up but it essentially has
nothing to do with the success of the
young turks like the young turks or not
it's not predicated on this heroic
awakening that jenk had which could be a
grift or it might not and he
just yeah it seems pretty clear he was
kind of a moderate republican in
in college and now he's not okay that's
it so the right creates cults of
personality around these people
in the way that left doesn't and it
makes it really appealing financially
okay second piece money
there just is more money available for
this stuff
on the right than there is on the left
i've seen it firsthand and we've dealt
with all sorts of different groups and
there just is on the right there are
tons of well-funded groups
that love to throw money at people who
are
doing the grift so to speak um these
libertarian groups that pay to bring
people to college campuses and you can
get
nice speaking fees uh depending on your
level your profile
you know the speaking fee can can be
more or less there really isn't much of
that
on the left uh the few times i've been
paid to speak at colleges it was that
the college had like a donor-funded
thing of
let's bring people to speak there were
never groups
in fact whenever i get invited by
left-leaning groups they say we have no
money
um organizations that then will
fund you know interview series on
different programs and these types of
things
uh donations as well even just
soliciting
the enlightened centrism tim poole as an
example who raised
a ton of money as someone who said he
was like mostly a bernie guy and all
this stuff but
then 90 of his content became
criticizing the left and praising trump
he raised a whole bunch of money with
the idea that he
who had he was on one side but he sees
this and the other and now he's got this
whole nice neat little package as the
arbiter of what's
what's right and what's wrong um he was
able to raise a ton of money on the idea
of launching
such a website that would just give you
the news
tm some they figured out how to do the
news and people donated like crazy to it
that appeals to
to right wingers um and i know someone
will say oh left i'm a left winger i
donated to that okay fine but
the the left does not reward that that
stuff that type of grifting um
ideologically
in terms of the cults of personality
around people
nor financially that's the explanation
as i see it that's the explanation as
i've
experienced it from within and remember
i told the story
of this radio consultant who met with me
years ago and said you know
do you really care about like what
you're saying because if you just want
to be a performer
there is a need right now for shows like
yours or you know
at the time a really young guy but on
the right i could get you syndicated and
we could triple your salary
and i've told that story before there
was no such thing available to me on the
left
and i'm glad i turned it down and
everything worked out fine no regrets
whatsoever so those are my thoughts on
the profitability
of the left-wing grift versus the
right-wing grift or the lack thereof
when it comes to the left-wing rift
send me more thoughts about what you
think might uh explain that difference
hey david could fighting vote by mail in
2020
backfire horribly for republicans
i think it could i think it could you
know i went back and looked at some of
the history of this
in the late 80s republicans started
working
to expand the appeal of vote by mail
because republicans looked at the
demographics and they realized
we skew older and we may do
disproportionately better
if we make it easier to vote and voting
by mail would make it easier to vote
particularly to older folks who may
no longer be driving or may have limited
mobility
or for whatever other reason maybe would
be more likely to vote if it's easier
for them
and they started to work
on a plan to expand vote by mail
and to make sure that their electorate
knew that that was going on
those are the same i mean they're not
literally the same people but that's the
same republican party
that even in 2018 was still looking at
oh let's put a let's require a mail-in
a mail ballot dropbox at every early
voting site
in the state they were doing that in
2018. in comes donald trump
we have the pandemic and it really
starts to seem
that more vote by mail is going to be
bad for donald trump
so in 2020 the republican party doesn't
want 80 that a lot of people don't even
know is a 180 and starts opposing vote
by mail it'll lead to fraud
it'll lead to you know all these
different things that didn't happen
and it turned out that if it helped in
2020 it didn't help enough
in the sense that republicans still lost
the senate and republicans still lost
the white house
but now there is concern among some
republicans including in florida
that it's a runaway freight train that
can't be stopped the momentum of
stopping mail in voting and indeed
dozens of the hundreds of bills that
we've seen put forward by republicans
since
the november election and since biden's
inauguration
would further limit early voting vote by
mail
et cetera strengthen voter id laws to
make it more difficult to vote all of
that stuff
the washington post spoke to a florida
state republican party official who said
we are worried about this and so while
publicly
they feel the pressure to at least say
they're
in favor of all the stuff republicans
are doing florida republicans
know that uh particularly with
elderly and military voters which what
groups do they have left
even the military when both elderly and
military
went more for biden in 2020 than they
typically do for democrats but
these are two of the strongest
republican voting groups some
republicans in florida are
privately saying can we publicly push
this stuff
but then privately try to exempt older
people
and military to make it really easy for
them to keep voting by mail or voting
early or whatever the case may be so
the answer to the question could
opposing vote by mail
and early voting back fire on
republicans it absolutely could
what will they now do publicly to try to
figure out a way
to thread that needle i don't know and i
don't really care
if it does end up backfiring on them
it's it's they they have to uh what's
the you have to let you made the bed
now sleep in it or something like that
uh
eat the oats you sow i don't even know
i'm i'm looking for
proverbs and similes and analogies here
and failing
but this is a problem of their own
making and now they're going to have to
deal with it
david rudy giuliani is finally
formally under investigation do you
think he will end up serving prison time
you know ev every time i answer one of
these questions with
no he's not going to go to prison i get
emails from people saying
david you fool
you are making it less likely that these
people will go to prison
by saying it's unlikely they're going to
go to prison no i'm not
my show's audience this show is just not
nearly big enough for me to say that and
for it to have any kind of effect rudy
giuliani is not going to go to prison
rudy giuliani is 76 years old
and i'm not saying he shouldn't be
investigated or prosecuted as a result
of that
we now know there's an investigation
into rudy going on
his home in office were raided last week
as we reported
he may have broken lobbying law he may
have broken all sorts of laws we don't
know what's going on with rudy giuliani
it's possible that the investigation
will lead to charges for rudy giuliani
if there are charges against rudy
giuliani the most
common scenario that i would expect
because of rudy giuliani's place in
society
and his access and his privilege would
be that
there is some kind of a plea agreement
or cooperation agreement
michael cohen trump's former lawyer
believes that rudy would
flip and spill the beans on trump
because rudy doesn't want to get in
trouble himself
so i think that there would be some kind
of plea deal if there's no plea deal
and it actually and if if there is a
plea deal anything
rudy pleads to would have no jail time
there's no doubt about it let's say
there's no plea deal
and this thing actually goes to trial is
it going to be a guilty verdict
i don't know if there is a guilty
verdict we're like four or five
maybes in right now if there is a guilty
verdict
uh there may be no jail time anyway
associated
with that as per the judge and even if
by this
time when rudy will be 77 or 78 or 79
who knows how long this thing could go
on
even if there is jail time i would fully
expect
that rudy's lawyer whoever it is at the
time who knows how many lawyers rudy
will have been through at that point in
time
i would expect rudy's lawyer would
successfully argue that the sentence be
suspended or that it be home confinement
or whatever based on rudy's age and
possible health uh situation
so when you put all of that together i
think the odds of rudy ever seeing
uh any prison time are i mean i think
one in a thousand
is it's when these when the percentages
are so small it's hard to make them
really
tangible is it one in a thousand that
rudy sees
jail time i know it's not one in a
hundred is it one in two thousand
but if i were a betting man on even odds
i'm saying no you would have to give me
some crazy odds for me to bet that rudy
sees the inside of a jail cell other
than for some reason
unrelated to him being being prosecuted
and charged
if you disagree with me let me know
i'm open to having my mind changed but i
don't see it we have a fantastic
bonus show today what yes
there's an extra show every day for our
members
sign up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman